[Musique]
Hier, je pensais qu'il
y avait cette anxiété lorsque vous rechargez, vous
pouvez voir que littéralement l'argent
va juste et cela crée ce sentiment d'
anxiété continue quant à la façon dont je vais
continuer à faire ça, comment vais-je continuer à
payer ça  si vous n'avez pas d'argent
et que vous ne mettez rien là-bas,
vous n'avez ni gaz ni électricité, alors qu'êtes-
vous censé faire,
je vérifie toujours ici, je
regarde toujours combien je '  Je me suis habitué
du début de la journée à la fin
de la journée et pour que cela
me dise jusqu'à présent aujourd'hui, le gaz et
l'électricité ont coûté six livres 78 et
il n'est que 12 heures et demie.
[Musique]
tous mes appareils sont  éteint la plupart du
temps, il n'y a rien qui soit allumé à
part le réfrigérateur et évidemment la chaudière
et c'est pour l'eau chaude et des trucs comme
ça tout le reste est éteint
rien ne reste allumé à moins que vous ne
l'utilisiez réellement
[Musique]
Je pense que leur idée de  la façon dont les gens
vivent est très différente de la
réalité parce qu'ils ne vivent pas ce
genre de vie
euh et ils ne connaissent probablement pas les gens
qui vivent ce genre de vie donc c'est un
concept pour eux ce n'est pas une réalité mais
pour nous tous  c'est une réalité
[Musique]
le gouvernement et les régulateurs doivent
interdire le transfert forcé de personnes sur des
compteurs à prépaiement immédiatement ils peuvent le
faire ils peuvent le faire maintenant et ils peuvent
le faire sans aucun frais pour un contribuable qui
doit être la première étape  cet hiver
étranger